kind of Engineers
have you guys been to Disney do you know
what this fast pass thing is this
[ __ ] communist [ __ ] you got a
book like 60 days in advance if you
don't do that you're [ __ ] and you're
getting a fast pass of like the teacup
ride or some [ __ ] that nobody else wants
anyway so how did you improve it sir
you didn't improve it you built the
initial piece of [ __ ] you have any
[ __ ] hours I waited for a goddamn
choo choo train because of your dumb ass
fast system you should be fired three
hours I'm waiting for a [ __ ] Avatar
ride playing [ __ ] what's that goddamn
game where you put the phone up to your
forehead
my wife nine years younger than me don't
know nothing you have many times out
motion's eleven is that the one with
Mindy Kaley all right just go the
[ __ ] so you've been together for how
many years I'm married
what's the hesitation
hey Jesus [ __ ] this guy dude oh I'm
sorry am I making you miserable with
your significant other I think that's
called payback you [ __ ] with your stupid
[ __ ] socialist fast pass ticket
Bernie Sanders ass amusement park idea
you have to [ __ ] France